I am here with film composer Alexandre
display hello a the oscar-winning
composer of the shape of water the grand
Budapest hotel this is truly an honor
and I'm so very thankful for you to join
me how are you today I'm very well thank
you thank you for having me here yeah in
Burbank in Burbank nothing but the best
here in Burbank and we're gonna go right
into it because I know I have you for a
little bit of time we're talking about
Isle of Dogs which is one of my favorite
movies of the year
but I want to start with your
collaborations with Wes Anderson this is
your I believe fourth collaboration how
did you who's one of my favorite
filmmakers of all time you started on
fantastic mr. Fox how did you get
involved with Wes Anderson through a
friend of ours
Stephen Gaghan I just met him one yuning
and I think that Stephens wedding
actually in New York and and the West
mentioned that he had a project maybe
you know and he would be in Paris
editing if I would be interested and and
that's where he started well and and I
knew his work from you know from his
previous movies but he had never done
animation at the time right was that a
different kind of a project for you
because you knew Wes Anderson from
obviously live-action and his movies is
there a particular challenge at a doing
a score for animation say live-action I
know you moved on and did moonrise
kingdom and grand Budapest but it is
there something different in the way you
compose film well this especially you
win with I think that the puppets you
know with the stop-motion it's very
special it's different from animation
you know the processed animation I think
when there's little digital puppets you
you feel something very close to your
childhood even more because they're real
kind of objects like the one you had in
your in your bedroom as a child so so we
really throws you back to to that to go
out your small bedroom
and the nice thing about it is that you
can of course the world of sand is
completely open because it's not reality
and I remember mr. Fox at first there
was this idea of doing a you know
classical animation score with big
Orchestra and because of this dimension
of these little puppets I thought maybe
it's too big maybe we should keep this
childhood filling this this intimacy and
bring the in the orchestra to his head
to its essence is something very very
very small actually we just used one
instrument of each section of an
orchestra like a minimum a miniscule
Orchestra I don't think it was you know
it was and I think it was much more in
face with white or some screen yeah oh
god I love your underscores and
soundtracks guy here movie scores I grew
up with them I listen to them instead of
pop music anything I put on film scores
a lot of you horse so this is the
hearing that is making me geek out in a
way that I didn't think I would but here
I am but that makes me think of Isle of
Dogs because I love dogs was such a
different sounding score for you I know
it's very based in Japanese culture I
noticed not a lot of like violin I
didn't hear strings definitely drums you
know what was your how did you get into
that did you study kind of Japanese
culture did you go into it that way
because it is a very you're talking
about fantastic mr. Fox this is
completely different in my opinion well
if you look at the story it's it's it's
like a young knight trying to go into a
quest you know he's looking for someone
for his dog nobody but it's like a you
know a medieval tale and there's several
ways of doing that we could have gone to
the again classical symphonic emotional
very somatic some maybe over sentimental
you can hear in many
animation movies or go the other way and
think well the story is very emotional
already it's this boy who has lost his
parents and he's he's isolated on the
Treasure Island he needs to go through
crazy adventures maybe maybe the
audience can feel the emotions without
us pushing them so now to come back to
the Japanese influence I've always been
very near to the Japanese culture from
various reasons she's have a child and
so I knew that instrumentation I would
also avoid any shockwatch she or you
know shamisen B were all too many
obvious instruments but the Tycho's were
there from the beginning in our
conversations with with West because
they refer to this archaic medieval
heavy heavyweight sound you know this
beating sound that you you hear
everywhere in the villages in in Japan
since the order ages so that's the core
of the score now how do you bring an
element of your Occidental culture into
this how do you bring this offside
imaginative world that was brings in all
of his films without being just Japanese
and the idea was that if I bring in
instruments we have which have nothing
to do with the Japanese music it will be
very very interesting to us in a
position so there's four saxophones four
recorders okay and three French ons and
in the double bass sometimes we double
these sections but that's so it's it's
even though the trams are very you know
organized and doing this very repetitive
obsessive March the race is bouncing
around almost like a jazzy score because
don't forget there's a spy story
yes it is yeah I almost noticed like the
use of the drums kind of is in place of
a like a recognizable theme like musical
theme exactly so as your walk is you're
going through the movie
it's the drums that I hear it's the
drummer yes it's the trams taking you by
the arm yes and taking you through the
story and you do all the adventures yeah
and that's what made it so powerful to
me because the you know I was introduced
to your music late but Deathly Hallows
Part 1 Harry Potter started following
your career the differences in the
themes you do the different music that
you make the different themes that I
love and have fallen in love with this
one though just hit me over the head and
it was just brilliant and so I love
hearing that now with you we worked on
after fantastic Fox moonrise kingdom
grand Budapest with Isle of Dogs is does
Wes Anderson call you up and say do you
want to do this and you immediately say
yes or do you have to go what are you
working on what we do you want to know
the the premise the concept as it was
well there's a few directors who have
been very loyal to me and who have been
also very loyal to and it's time they
call me and this there's a huge schedule
conflict which sometimes happens because
some directors go quickly than I do and
I certainly have a project and my
schedule is filled up and I just said
you can't do it but I've tried to be
very faithful to - to the directors so
Wes
caused me I don't even ask a question
that's how I great what would it be but
yeah like what would it be when do we
start this what I mean when do we sir I
would do the same thing and that that's
amazing and do you does that always
happen with your other certain projects
that other directors maybe that you
haven't worked with I think of Guillermo
del Toro and your Oscar win for the
shape of water is that another director
that calls you and you just say when do
I start well
my wine you first respectively but the
movie about ship revolta it was more
when doing I went to Harry the script
yeah yeah told me the story good mm-hmm
okay yeah I need to get to the bottom of
this once okay she's in the bathtub okay
and then they have sex
mm-hmm all right so you waited for the
script I mean I've already said yes to
whatever project dirimu is doing yeah
you know and there's there's a huge
schedule conflict which I will make sure
it doesn't happen there's no way I'm not
working with Guillermo again yeah as
much as mine yeah especially after the
shape of water I you were my I circled
you on my Oscar Oscar ballot I was
thrilled when he won so congratulations
on that and it makes me think too you
started you know very early on with a
director Jacques I'm looking for some
good yeah yeah yes on sisters brothers
and that was your seventh film I believe
he worked with it yes yes yes escort his
first filming in 94 94 I wasn't I was
eight years old long relationship of you
know friendship and and and work
relationship he's a he's the best french
director alive I would say of the new
generation of directors for the last 20
years and his world is is very special
very different mm-hm
he's a great artist and each time his
movies offering me a different approach
a different sound and what I learned I
think by working with Jack and and I
think built also my my personality as a
composer is to always be trying not to
photocopy what is on screen and try and
expand it or
or make it even more perform you know
get go grab the depth of field orifice
his camera is is narrowing the viewer
the view of the audience make the music
make it bigger almost trying to to play
with with his with his missile sent in
as an opponent yeah dancing with him as
an opponent yeah and I've learned a lot
by doing that you know he's sisters
brothers it what is the Western so yeah
if I was starting okay to Western so
there would be French horns and bras and
pom pom pom pom pom pom pom bro you know
all those things we've heard so many
times you know okay fair enough that's
been done by Emma Bernstein by Bruce
Brockton she's been all America
Morricone era as it's been older the the
fall Kish sounds you know of a dead man
all these great his Western tropes yes
are so wonderful or yes Neil Young score
you know all these things but so I I
just needed to find something else there
again you you're confronting yourself to
to exploration to danger and with
Jacques it's always always always the
the mantra hmm what can we explore that
we we haven't yeah and as is it your
first Western that you know yeah and so
what is it about this it was it Jacques
that got you involved and not the genre
or was a little bit of both it was like
I want to do a Western and of course I'm
doing it with you John I know it's Jack
yeah he calls me and I say yes you would
have been a movie about the beauty
silent that's great yeah the the Western
is such an interesting when you're
composing I mean you brought up some
just kind of tropes in there and it's
such a fascinating thing because I think
to your earlier works you've done the
period pieces you've done monster movies
you've done you know stop-motion is
there something
genre out there that you haven't done
that you're looking to maybe dip your
toes in in the future you know I'm not
sure it's a genre that that excites me
is the story the relationship between
the story and the director that I'm
going to work with the vision that the
director has his point of view if I see
that it's strong and that the the story
resonates with me you know then I'm I'm
happy to go and I learned from you know
from scripts I receive and stories that
have you know like the King's Speech
when I learned a lot from from doing
that film or even girl with the Pearl
Earring
I think it's movie makes you grow as a
as a film composer because you you try
to expand your knowledge in general your
culture in general and also your musical
abilities and and the territories that
you try to explore but it doesn't have
to be in the jar I think I think you can
explore in appeared please like garbage
about hearing as much as in Harry Potter
fantasy or in there and no in operation
finale or whatever you know or a
stop-motion though right is there a
difference in in your take on composing
for some of the smaller more intimate
character movies versus say a Harry
Potter or a Godzilla big blockbusters
you know do you do you tackle them
differently maybe sound wise yes yeah
you know that you you're you're you're
trying to keep to keep your voice down
why you know Harry Potter or Godzilla
you have to you have to bark really loud
Yogesh must be a big big big sound so
your rights think about that but that
being said I still believe that what I
love about cinema is the narrative it's
the is the storyline and the characters
and I always try to be as near as I can
from the characters I was talking about
dancing with Jacques ideas and open and
Kelly to his miss onsen which is
sometimes very dark and very active and
my music can be very calm and very wide
in the position and he creates some kind
of a vibration between the two well the
same way I try to develop this vibration
and the more I go the more I want to be
inside the film inside the picture you
know that my my score is not separate
from from the image like if I was one
more actor on the set playing with the
actors so I I really try and emphasize
the technology of the characters their
their emotions and be I think so
whatever it is as a jar that's my main
goal I think because I think you as an
audience you react to the emotions that
the characters sent to you mm-hmm
not to the building falling that's you
know that's another it's what the eyes
of the actress or the actor brings into
your your cortex that is a stronger
mm-hmm and you it's very interesting you
here to talk about the the process of it
I mean art you know there are themes in
your work that I notice as a I'm a film
lover sure but I love scores so when a
score hits me and I'm putting it on I
buy the album I'm listening over and
over again I might be an outliar is it
something that you're conscious of going
in to score a movie that I want a
recognizable theme like maybe like
Godzilla I want the audience to know
like cuz I for me personally I saw some
jaws in Godzilla
I saw the idea of not showing the
creature for a while and I felt like
your score really kind of was underneath
there but I noticed it very early on is
that conscious on your on your scoring
well there again each movie opens a
different window some movies I start
with a very strong theme at the opening
for example opening credits and then I
keep it very discreet for a while and at
some points a section of this motif that
we've heard comes back or and some other
movies like the imitation game or even
shape of water
the theme is part of the of the strong
DNA of the film and it's recurring and
it's haunting you but but but but but
all the movies come conflict you to that
which occurred yeah it doesn't really
work because his narrative is different
more fragmented and more abstract and if
a scene was recurring all the time it
could be it wouldn't be in phase it
would be Alex on display showing of her
listen to my wonderful melody right and
that's not that's not what I do
I I work for for cinema otherwise I
would only write music for for concert
and I'd be a genius
at listening to my own piece notice I
mean I'm I play in a team it's a
collaborative work so I'm um I'm
honoring the film as much as I can with
what I with my ideas I I was on your
website in those visiting I was looking
at a lot of your influences Nino Rota
just a thousand of them yep
maurices y'all know I can't speak in
your native tongue so I apologize for
butchering your language but there was
an interesting thing I noticed that you
were maybe thinking about going into
film composing and then you saw Star
Wars and John Williams of course and
then I think of that missed opportunity
for me as a fan you were gonna score
rogue one at one point that was
scheduling right and there's is that a
regret is that something you wish you
got your hands on so is a regret not to
be able to go to the end of a project
but you know now I've learned that some
of these huge movies either give you a
time frame and in fact it's it's so you
know they're so I put everything in ever
every body in every everyone in danger
in the studio it's got to be a hit you
know they they cost a lot of money and
so they take the time they need and that
was maybe naive to think that on time
I'd be able to score it and then move on
to Toolik business movie which I was
wanting to work with for many many years
so I just had to you know what to finish
yeah okay do you hope in the future you
could do another Star Wars movie maybe
maybe a Marvel movie or a DC some of
these big blockbusters that are just
taking over the our pop culture that
would be interesting cuz I've never done
that yeah aside from Harry Potter which
is something a bit different
I've I've never had the the moment so
far mm-hmm
as the opportunity but maybe it will
come because it's maybe a my the music I
write doesn't make people think that I
would do that and actually maybe that's
what excites me don't put myself in
danger yeah and you know it goes
somewhere big that that I which idea of
Godzilla of course and butter a little
bit you know somehow but in another
direction which I've never done maybe it
would be a real challenge for me well as
a fan of yours and knowing your music
the way I do I could see you fitting
into a Marvel a DC and especially Star
Wars which a fan on YouTube actually
took some of your music and cut it into
the rogue one trailer oh yes yeah they
wanted to know what your sound would be
like with road one I thought it was it
worked for me I was a fan of it very
much so so I want to appreciate I really
appreciate you coming in I know you got
to head out for Isle of Dogs oh is this
a score you're really proud of
we're heading into Awards
is that something you think about it all
about you know you've won now two Oscars
is this something you're looking at
you're very proud of is that a hope or
is it you don't care you just want to do
your thing well it's a great honor it's
a great joy to receive an Oscar me and
you it's it's it's a dream for somebody
who works in the industry whose worship
cinema since I was a child and and being
French and being invited that this you
know giving me receiving these honors
after the Masters that you you mentioned
like John Williams but also the French
movie shall deliver a miracle or Gabriel
I it it was a great joy for me and
receiving his second Oscar was
incredible I was if you look at my face
I did that night of the Oscar and you
know I'm 10 years 10 years old and and
the color globe just before in the BAFTA
and it was incredible last year so you
always hope that it happens again sure
it's not the last time but it's not what
you stopped my moto what what brings me
need to composing is the film's I'm I'm
excited about if they if they hit the
the awards is fantastic I'm happy for
the movie happy for me
if they don't okay I've tried to do my
best job and I could win every year but
I can't write well I want to thank you
very much for coming near now
Alexander's a spot I am a huge fan I
hope everybody enjoyed this little
section form the Reilly roundtable good
luck with Isle of Dogs good luck with
everything else do you have one project
that you're working on next that you can
tell everybody about her well I was just
finished little opera chamber opera in
Europe that's been being performed soon
and and starting the secret life of pets
to party yeah all right well are there
any mention with these great friends at
the elimination Christian oh yeah under
a fantastic team oh well that's great
well the Isle of Dogs is out now you can
check it out
check out his amazing unique score this
is what we were here for to talk about
again
Alexander thank you very much for taking
time to sit with me I appreciate it